So now that we know a little bit about class
variables, let's move on to another idea in object oriented
programming, which is that in Python, all classes come with
some pre-existing class variables. One of them is called doc. Now
this variable has got underscores on both sides of its
name. Let's see this variable in action. So here I
am at the Python Shell window, with the Python prompt.
And I can type a program in here like 2+2 and
it gives me the correct answer. Now I want
us to recall this class called turtle that we had
used some time back while drawing shapes. So I
can just import that class turtle here. There, then let
me see what happens when I use the class
name. turtle.Turtle. Remember this was the name of the module
or the file and this was the class name.
So if I use the class name with the prepackaged
variable called doc. Let me see what it prints out.
I get some documentation on the class turtle.
Now I wonder if I can use this variable doc
with my class movie. So, I'm back to the code
for the class movie and behind this file is my
other Python file where, I'm defining a whole bunch of
instances of class Movie. Let me go back to the
code for class Movie here for a second. Now, here,
I'm going to add some documentation, at the beginning of
the class Movie. You may have noticed that I use
triple quotes, to define my documentation. Now what I can
do with triple quotes, is I can create documentation in
multiple lines. For now I just have the one line.
So I'm going to save this file, and then go
to my other Python file. And here, I'm going to
scroll all the way to the bottom, and comment out any
sort of print statements. There. Now, I will try to print out my class Movie,
which is accessed by saying, media.Movie. I
will try to print out its documentation [SOUND].
There. Let me save and run this file.
And there it is. The documentation for my
class Movie. Notice how I accessed it though. I
accessed it using my class name, which is movie
and a predefined class variable, called doc. So, now
that we have successfully used this variable called doc.
I have a question for you. You know much
like the variable doc, Python has a few more
predefined variables these include the variable name and module.
By the way more information about these
is also available through links in the instructor
notes. What I want you to do is
read through the documentation in the instructor notes
and then I want you to use these variables name and module, in a new
program. Once you have done that, please come
back to the screen and check this box.